das war die sensation im letzten jahr
harvard-professor edward äußert sie die
these dass das interstellare objekt 10
uhr eine alien sonder oder der rest
einer alien sonne sein könnte ein licht
segel fakt war das objekt wurde so stark
vom strahlungsdruck der sonne
beschleunigt dass das nur mit der
beschaffenheit eines licht segels
erklärt werden konnte spricht das objekt
musste extrem dünn und leicht sein wenn
ein natürlicher ursprung wäre damit
sogar unwahrscheinlich und jetzt gibt es
eine weitere studie und auch die sagt ja
es ist ein licht segel und wir wissen
auch woher es kommt und das ist noch
mehr davon gibt bought klicks und
science fiction hier gibt's täglich
spannendes heinz videos abonniert den
kanal nur dann verpasst er nichts
herzlich willkommen
als ich vor mehr als 15 jahren mit den
planungen von klicks um anfing schlug
mir blankes unverständnis entgegen video
im internet die soll das denn gehen
die rechner sind doch viel zu langsam
und die übertragung im netz die sind
doch auch zu langsam ich aber das wird
doch alles schneller ja aber und dann
wurden immer weitere irgendwelche
rahmenbedingungen der damaligen zeit her
genommen als argumente gegen video im
internet naja ich bild recht wie die
leute damals war aber eine andere
realität einfach nicht denkbar
die prozessorleistung die datenraten von
heute waren einfach unvorstellbar und so
ist es mit vielen künstliche intelligenz
wird die und die fähigkeiten haben in
zukunft skeptiker niemals warum weil
ihre vorstellungskraft nicht ausreicht
oder der klimawandel die temperatur wird
um mehrere grad steigen inseln werden
untergehen der meeresspiegel steigt nein
so schlimm wird das niemals wie wir
heute wissen eine krasse
fehleinschätzung weil die
vorstellungskraft nicht ausreicht oder
ob das interstellare objekt ist eine
alien sonder oder ein teil davon
diese möglichkeit bleibt nach der
einschätzung des leiters der abteilung
astronomie der harvard university
professor erblüht moment als einzige
erklärung war es im moment anders nicht
erklären kann was war hier unter den
videos zum thema los
mannomann und warum weil die
vorstellungskraft dafür nicht ausreicht
die nasa sagt dass wir so oder so in den
nächsten 20 jahren spuren von aliens
finden werden also warum soll es dann
kein interstellare objekt sein wenn die
nasa sagt in den nächsten jahren also
den nächsten 20 jahren bedeutet dass in
den nächsten 7300 tagen wird es
passieren die chancen stehen also an
jedem tag eins zu 7299 das ist so
unglaublich viel höher als im lotto eine
million zu gewinnen also die chancen
darauf und trotzdem passiert das ständig
wenn wir also ein höchst seltsames
objekt aufspüren sind die chancen also
mathematisch extrem hoch dass das genau
dieser moment sein könnte und das
einzige was dagegen spricht ist die
mangelnde vorstellungskraft und jetzt
kommt ein weiteres indiz hinzu eine neue
studie unterstützt die these dass es
sich um ein extrem leichtes objekt
handeln muss das nur so durch den
strahlungsdruck der sonne beschleunigt
werden konnte denn wenn das objekt diese
eigenschaften hat dann hat es auch eine
weitere bemerkenswerte eigenschaft vor
eintritt in unser sonnensystem hätte
ohne humor nämlich eine sehr ähnliche
geschwindigkeit im betrag und richtung
wie die plejaden sterne die autor der
studie thomas marshall banks hat
daraufhin untersucht wie sich ein licht
segel von den plänen zu uns in unser
sonnensystem bewegen würde
wie würden staub und gas im
interstellaren raum auf das licht segel
einwirken und seine flugbahn zu uns
beeinflussen und auch hier wird wieder
die these von apple bestätigt ein licht
segel würde sich genauso verhalten alles
passt zusammen wenn es ein licht siegel
ist gem
und er sagt und hier werden wir wieder
bei der wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung wenn
es ein solches objekt zu uns geschafft
hat dann muss es mehr davon geben noch
ein baum sein vorschlag wenn wir das
wissen also und wenn wir vor allem
wissen woher diese objekte kommen und
welche flugbahn sie haben dann müssen
wir jetzt nur noch in diese richtung
schauen und müssten dann solche objekte
mit monaten bis zu einem jahr vor dem
durch flug durch unser sonnensystem mit
hoher wahrscheinlichkeit finden dann
wären
wir in der lage eine sonde zu dem objekt
zu schicken um es näher zu untersuchen
wow das ist wirklich der hammer
demnach wären wir in der lage
wahrscheinlich schon bald ein solches
objekt zu untersuchen es bleibt spannend
wie finden wir aliens auf dieses video
klicken hier anschauen
neugier zonen abonnieren und ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran